lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
hablar sobre cómo visualizar
distribuciones de datos y después
analizar dichas visualizaciones para
eventualmente llegar a algo llamado
curva de densidad comenzamos con un
ejemplo sencillo para repasar algunos
conceptos digamos que tengo 16
estudiantes y les pido que registren
cuántos vasos de agua beben por día
durante los últimos 30 días y calculen
el promedio así que este dato nos indica
que un estudiante debe en promedio 0.5
vasos de agua al día
esta persona probablemente está muy
deshidratada esta otra persona bebe 8.1
vasos de agua al día en promedio durante
los últimos 30 días sin duda está mejor
hidratada si queremos visualizar esto
podemos elaborar un programa de
frecuencia donde podemos crear algunas
clases por ejemplo esta clase es para
valores mayores o iguales a 0 y menores
a 1 aquí vemos que dos datos caen en
esta clase y es por eso que la barra de
dicha clase llega hasta el 2
esta clase de acá va de mayor o igual a
3 y menor que 4 noten que hay 4 datos
que están en esta clase y es por eso que
la altura de esta barra en el histograma
llega hasta el 4 esta es una buena forma
de visualizar una distribución pero a
ustedes quizá les preocupe más cuál es
el porcentaje de mis datos que cae en
esas clases lo cual se vuelve de
especial interés cuando tenemos muchos
datos como por ejemplo 280 mil millones
340 millones 300 mil 70 datos el conocer
el total de los datos que caen en cada
clase no es tan útil pero conocer el
porcentaje que cae en cada clase es
mucho más útil para esos casos tenemos
el histograma de frecuencia relativa
noten que contiene los mismos datos pero
visualizados de otra forma en la primera
clase en lugar de que la altura de la
barra sea 2 la altura de la barra ahora
es 12.5 por ciento porque es eso porque
dos de los 16 datos caen en esta clase
dos dieciseisavos son 1
que a su vez es 12.5 por ciento en esta
clase de acá vean que la altura en lugar
de ser 4 como en el histograma anterior
ahora es 25% pero ambos histogramas
están diciendo lo mismo cuatro de los 16
datos caen en esta clase cuatro
dieciseisavos son un cuarto que a su vez
es el 25% ambos tipos de histogramas son
muy útiles y se utilizan todo el tiempo
pero también tenemos casos en donde hay
muchos más datos y queremos clases más
específicas en este caso lo que se puede
hacer es justamente hacer más
específicas nuestras clases
isa en lugar de que el ancho sea de un
vaso de agua en promedio al día podría
ser medio vaso de agua al día por lo que
esta primera clase podría ser mayor o
igual que 0 y menor que 0.5 esto nos
daría una imagen más clara de la
distribución de los datos y ahora estoy
suponiendo que tenemos más de 16 datos
quizá tenemos 16 millones de datos
aquí tendríamos los porcentajes del lado
izquierdo pero quizá esto no es
suficientemente bueno para lo que
queremos
quizá queremos visualizar los datos de
forma más específica y ahora el ancho de
cada clase es de un cuarto de vaso pero
quizá incluso esto no es suficiente
necesitamos que sea cada vez más y más
específica podemos imaginar hacia dónde
va esto podemos llegar a un punto en
donde nos aproximemos a un número
infinito de clases y cada clase es
infinitamente delgada tan delgada que
llegaremos a un punto en el que podemos
conectar las partes superiores de las
barras de manera que obtenemos una curva
real este tipo de curva es algo que
usamos en estadística y como les prometí
al inicio del vídeo
esta es la curva de densidad de la que
hablamos lo valioso de una curva de
densidad es que es una visualización de
la distribución en donde los datos
pueden tomar cualquier valor de manera
continua ya no se encuentran en sus
respectivas clases como interpretamos
esta visualización si observamos el
ínter
lo completo de 0 a 9 suponiendo que
ningún estudiante tiene un promedio
mayor que en 9 vasos al día de entre
nuestros 16 millones de datos entonces
el área bajo la curva en ese intervalo
será de 100 por ciento será el 100 por
ciento o 1.0 esto se va a cumplir para
cualquier curva de densidad toda el área
bajo la curva será igual al 100% ya que
representa todos los datos una curva de
densidad jamás tendrá un valor negativo
no veremos que la curva pase hacia abajo
y haga cosas extrañas ya que tenemos
claro esto pensemos sobre cómo lo vamos
a usar si yo quiero saber qué porcentaje
de mis datos se encuentran entre 2 y 4
vasos me fijo en ese intervalo y voy a
calcular el área bajo la curva dentro de
ese intervalo esta área será mayor o
igual que 0 y menor o igual a 100 % lo
que veo aquí me da la impresión de que
es cercano al 40% de toda el área bajo
la curva así que viéndolo así digo que
aproximadamente 40 por ciento de mí
kaim dentro de ese intervalo si yo les
preguntara qué porcentaje de los datos
es mayor que 3 entonces ustedes verían
esta área y parece que es el 50% aunque
de nuevo es sólo un estimado pueden ver
que incluso con los estimados una curva
de densidad es muy útil en el mundo real
los estadísticos a menudo tienen tablas
que pueden representar la información de
las curvas de densidad quizá tienen
programas de cómputo o herramientas
automatizadas además de que también
existen curvas de densidad bien
identificadas como la famosa curva de
campana que veremos más adelante y que
tiene datos precisos y herramientas muy
conocidas que permiten conocer el área
con exactitud lo último que les quiero
comentar es un error clave de concepto
de la curva de densidad si yo les
preguntara cuál porcentaje de mis datos
es exactamente igual a tres vasos de
agua al día y me refiero a que sea
exactamente igual a 3.000 000 y que
continua por siempre
exactamente 3 quizás se vean tentados a
decir bueno aquí está el 3 veamos cuál
es el punto en la curva que le
corresponde y parece que está un poco
por arriba de 0.2 así que podríamos
decir que es aproximadamente 20 por
ciento pero yo les digo que esto está
mal recuerden que el porcentaje de los
datos en un intervalo no está dado por
la altura de la curva sino que está dado
por el área bajo la curva de dicho
intervalo si hablamos de un valor
preciso como el ejemplo del valor 3
exacto no vamos a tener un área bajo la
curva la línea vertical que dibuje en el
número 3 no tiene un ancho lo que tiene
mucho sentido en el mundo real aun
cuando tengamos los datos de 16 millones
de personas es poco probable que alguno
de ellos beba exactamente 3 vasos de
agua al día me refiero a que no bebe un
átomo más ni un átomo menos que los 3
vasos probablemente haya muchas personas
entre 2.9 y 3.1 ninguno que sea
exactamente igual a tres vasos al día
normalmente al promedio es un estimado y
sabe 3.000 vasos al día o 2.999 nueve
vasos al día así que en lugar de eso
podemos preguntar cuál es el porcentaje
que cae en el intervalo mayor o igual
que 2.9 y menor o igual que 3.1 una vez
que tenemos un intervalo entonces si
podemos calcular el área en este caso ya
tenemos un intervalo que tiene anchura
que tiene el tamaño aproximado de esta
área amarilla que estoy señalando
podemos aproximar la con un rectángulo
aún cuando la parte superior de la curva
no sea plana se aproxima a un rectángulo
que tiene punto 2 de altura y cuál es el
ancho pasamos de 2.9 a 3.1 por lo que el
ancho es punto 2 calculamos el área
aproximada con este rectángulo
aproximado 0.2 x 0.2 nos da una área de
0.04 o podemos decir que aproximadamente
el 4% de los datos caen en este
intervalo